how's it going Wolfgang one of the most
anticipated things about Avengers 4 is
the storyline that's going to happen
with Bruce Banner and the Hulk I think
it was a huge surprise and shock to
everybody that we really didn't see the
Hulk much in Avengers infinity war
where's your guy
dude you embarrassed me from the Wizards
especially because in the trailers that
came out for Avengers infinity war we
saw the Hulk running in Wakanda I think
the majority of us thought that once the
Battle of Wakanda started and Bruce
Banner was in the Hulkbuster once it got
taken over the Hulk would bust out and
come to save the day
but according to the directors the Russo
brothers that is exactly why the Hulk
did not come out again as I've said in a
lot of my recent videos there is a lot
of commentary on the digital release of
Avengers infinity war and there is a lot
of new information that we're learning
that we're getting directly from the
source this isn't theory or guessing
this is directly from directors writers
producers are you yawning in the middle
of this while I'm breaking it down huh
did you hear what I said
and as far as the Hulk and Bruce Banner
are concerned as far as that characters
are concerned there seems to be a
certain direction that they're moving
towards and that seems to be like it's
Professor Hulk if you haven't had a
chance to get your hands on your own
copy of Avengers infinity war and watch
this commentary for yourself I am doing
a giveaway if you would like to enter my
giveaway for your chance to win a copy
of Avengers infinity war on blu-ray all
you have to do to enter is subscribe to
my channel like this video and comment
below with your favorite superhero
Marvel Studios has been developing the
story arc for the Hulk and Bruce Banner
for quite some time now and they pretty
much decided early on that the Hulk
can't have his own solo movie and
basically what they promised Mark
Ruffalo is that the Hulk would get his
time to shine over the course of a few
different movies for example Thor
Ragnarok was pretty much a Thor and
Hulk movie and it was a good mix of both
Banner and the Hulk
so in thor ragnarok we saw this
different dynamic with Banner and the
Hulk which was really that they had no
dynamic the Hulk had pretty much taken
over the body that him and banner share
for two years and finally banner comes
back and then banner makes it a point
that he doesn't ever want to turn back
into the Hulk because he might not ever
turn back to banner if he does but of
course at the end of thor ragnarok they
need the Hulk
so the Hulk comes to the rescue
and then everybody gets on the ship and
Asgard gets destroyed the movie ends and
we still see the Hulk standing there
with everybody it's not banner it's the
Hulk and then that's where Avengers
infinity war picks up in the opening
scene
Loki calls upon the Hulk the Hulk shows
up throws a few good punches in there on
Thanos but it's Thanos it really does
nothing and then Thanos proceeds to kick
the Hulk's butt
and then for the rest of the movie we
have Banner and the Hulk refuses to come
out and for a really long time pretty
much everybody thought that the reason
the Hulk wouldn't come out is because he
was afraid afraid of Thanos afraid to
face him again but as it turns out
that's not the case this is just further
development of their story arc in the
Avengers infinity war commentary from
the rusa brothers they explained that
the Hulk isn't afraid he's just kind of
tired of banner this is what the Russo
brothers had to say about going forward
with Bruce Banner and the Hulk this was
an interesting journey we went on with
banner trying to decide how he move him
forward in the Marvel Universe what
makes him unique as a character is that
there is a host body that is being
fought over by two distinct
personalities who hate each other and
both want control of the host body so we
fought an interesting direction to take
him in is what if banner who typically
uses the Hulk to solve crisis situations
what if the Hulk were no longer
interested in solving these problems for
banner so that the relationship is
becoming increasingly dysfunctional
that's what's going on here people have
speculated whether there was some fear
on the hoax part about having to face
Stannis again but I think ultimately
what it is is that he's tired of playing
hero to Bruce Banner
so the Hulk's not afraid of Thanos he's
just mad at Banner which it's the Hulk
he's always mad
kako I'm throwing shields at people
could kill me I know I'm sorry I just
got so angry all the time
oh oh but what does that mean now for
the story arc of Banner and the Hulk
well we have this official concept art
for Avengers 4 that was released and it
shows the Hulk it's not banner it's the
Hulk or maybe it's both he's wearing a
uniform and that's not like the Hulk at
all this implies that the Hulk was calm
enough and willing to comply with the
Avengers to put this uniform on this is
an entirely different Hulk that we're
used to seeing so what is going on here
the most likely explanation and what
everybody really believes we see here is
that we now have professor
Hulk in the comics professor Hulk is a
merger of three different people banner
the grey Hulk and savage Hulk now it's
worth noting that Professor Hulk was
originally called
the merged Hulk and eventually turned
into professor Hulk but they're pretty
much the same the only difference is
that professor Hulk had a ponytail in
the comics which I really hope they
don't do in the movie and it seems like
they're not going to so professor Hulk
rather than being a merger of three
different personalities was really its
own separate fourth personality and this
fourth personality represented banners
ideal self the professor hulk is
actually the larger of the Hult he's
larger than Savage Hulk and grey Hulk
but he has the face of banner while
professor Hulk is capable of being a lot
stronger than these other Hulk's he is a
lot more calm and he's also a lot more
intelligent than the normal version of
the Hulk because again this represents
banners ideal self its banners mind with
the Hulk's body this lines up perfectly
with the MCU right now because in Thor
Ragnarok Banner was afraid to turn back
into the Hulk because he thought he'd
never turn back into banner because the
Hulk would be in control but in Avengers
infinity war he needed the Hulk but the
Hulk refused to come out so really this
is an ideal Hulk for banner in the MCU
right now because he would still have
control but he would also have the Hulk
essentially
[Music]
there is a catch with Professor Hulk
though you just heard me mentioned that
Professor Hulk is capable of being one
of the stronger hulks and it's true he
is capable of being one of the stronger
hulks in a calm state he can lift an
excess of a hundred tons but and here's
the catch
he has a limitation put on him by banner
himself banner subconsciously installs a
type of safeguard in professor hulk and
what the safeguard does is that when the
professor Hulk's anger reaches a certain
level he will transform back into Bruce
Banner what are you crazy yes this
definitely sounds like something that
Bruce Banner in the MCU
would want because right now he's so
afraid that if he does turn back into
the Hulk he'll never turn back in the
Bruce Banner
so this safeguard makes a lot of sense
in the MCU right now because Bruce
Banner wouldn't have to worry about
becoming Bruce Banner again when he
turns into the Hulk and then of course
he could use the power of the Hulk so it
does really seem like professor Hulk is
being set up in Avengers 4 so right now
at the end of Avengers infinity war half
of the beans and existence got wiped out
by fan oh snap so of course all the
Avengers and heroes that are left
remaining after the snap are going to be
completely devastated not only
devastated that the other heroes and
Avengers have died but that half of the
universe died as well and they couldn't
stop it from happening
so moving forward figuring out some way
to possibly undo the snap Banner and the
Hulk are going to have to have a serious
conversation between the two of them and
as we saw in Thor Ragnarok the Hulk is
already becoming more intelligent on his
own he's having full-on conversations
with people and he's comprehending them
Mark Ruffalo himself an interview said
that the line between Bruce Banner and
the Hulk is becoming very blurred
so the merger between the two of them
has really already started so in this
conversation that banner will have to
have with the Hulk I think what the end
result will be is a compromise between
the two of them clearly with the snap
happening they're going to need banners
intelligence to somehow undo the snap or
go back in time but when that time comes
they're going to need the Hulk to be
able to fight and I think when that time
comes we'll get professor Hulk to me
this makes sense and it fits the story
perfectly and they did say that the Hulk
and Bruce Banner were going to get a big
story arc in Avengers 4 so it seems
pretty apparent to me that we're going
to get professor Hulk and Avengers 4
what do you all think do you agree do
you disagree
do you have theories of your own or is
there another hope that you'd like to
see I mean we'd all love to see world
brick or Hulk but I don't think we're
going to in this movie but hit me with
your thoughts in the comments below and
again don't forget about the giveaway
all you have to do to enter is subscribe
to my channel like this video and
comment below with your favorite
superhero thank you so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
you